Speaker 1: Let's speak to. Let's speak to Evan
from Boston. Evan, you were on the air.
Speaker 2: I David Pakman yes, I can.
Hey, I'm actually a new, new follower, new
listener, so I really appreciate the show
and appreciate your views on things. Thank
you. And my question is, you've talked about
this a little bit, if you have friends
or family that lean, lean Republican.
But, you know, kind of bought into the
Trump thing and are leaning away from it,
but, you know, if he becomes the
Republican nominee again, we'll probably
vote Republican again. How do you facilitate
conversations, maybe with folks who
aren't? Hopefully, in my opinion, right,
like not too far gone, right? Maybe they are.
Speaker 1: You know, I don't know because I don't
have any people like that in my family now. My my
girlfriend does have some people in her family
who are hard, right, Trumpists. But they live in
a different part of the country. And neither she
nor I really have any contact with them. I mean,
we see what they're posting to Facebook, but I
don't I don't know what I would say because I
just don't have any people like that in my family.
Speaker 2: That's a. How does is a good question
and how does your how does your girlfriend feel
about it as she's the one with the the familial
ties, if you know what I mean? Yeah. I mean,
Speaker 1: she thinks that they're wrong
about everything and does not engage in any
political discussions with them whatsoever.
Speaker 2: Gotcha, but still
kind of does she facilitate a
Speaker 1: healthy relationship
Speaker 2: out our relationship? Yeah, she
Speaker 1: has very little
relationship with most of those people.
Speaker 2: It. Yeah. Yeah, that's how I mean,
that's how I'm slowly and slowly going in my life
is, I guess, in a similar position as you where
she has no relationship with these folks at all.
Speaker 1: And here's the thing I don't think any
one thing is the right thing to do as that when
I get this question a lot. How should I maintain
or not maintain or how should I confront people?
It's all about what kind of a relationship you
want to have. Some people legitimately say, I
value family no matter what they think. And I
want to maintain a relationship, so we will agree
either to disagree or to not talk
about politics or whatever. I mean,
I think my family in Argentina is an example
of that, where in Argentina, all my family is
basically on the left. But you have people who
love Cristina Kirchner and that whole regime
and people who don't like it. And typically,
they just agree not to talk about politics at
family gatherings. And it sort of works OK.
Speaker 2: Gotcha. Yeah. So I guess the next
step for me is to figure out where and I guess
is where I'm struggling personally at, where my
values lie. I'm going to be a person who
is like, Yeah, family, no matter what or
when your family's pretty. A bunch of jerks.
Speaker 1: Maybe, maybe not. Yeah, and I mean,
listen, there's a difference between. There's
people who think there should be a 10 percent flat
tax on everything. It's like, OK, all right. Well,
that's mean we can disagree on that versus I think
the Jews are the devil and are going to hell.
That's going to be someone very difficult to
put differences aside with, you know?
Speaker 2: Right, right. And I think I
think at first it was leaning towards the the
first example. Right. And then when Trump came
out and kind of made it more normal to be a
little bit more racist, to be a little bit
more vocal about these views, I started to see a
different side of my family as the result of that.
But that was OK to say these things, right?
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. And so now it's like, you know,
and then also as I'm growing older. Twenty eight,
having been more developed cognitively and being
able to kind of like, recognize these things
as, you know, when you're 12, 14, 15, not being
able to recognize these these types of things.
Speaker 1: Well, let us know how it works out.
Speaker 2: Yeah, thanks. I appreciate the advice.
Speaker 1: All right. There's Evan from Boston,
and that is going to do it for us today. We will
take more calls next week. I look forward to it.